the fallout continues from Michael Cohen
and Paul Manafort New York opens another
line of investigation into President
Trump and president Trump leaps into the
South Africa situation I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show see
normally they call it the summer
doldrums because not a lot happens but
then there was the Trump administration
and stuff happens all the time we're
gonna jump into all of it in just one
second but first let's talk a little bit
about our national debt it's 21 trillion
dollars and Counting that is at least a
large chunk money we owe other countries
or to our unfunded liabilities it's
greater than the entire economic output
of the United States so what is your
plan for hyperinflation if the stilts
fall out from under the economy you can
hedge against inflation in hedge against
uncertainty and instability with
precious metals gold is a safe haven
against uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified and yours should be too I
don't mean take all your stocks and sell
it for gold I mean some of your money
should be in precious metals as a hedge
against volatility in the market and
right now thanks to a little-known IRS
tax law you can even move your IRA or
eligible 401k into an IRA backed by
physical gold and silver it's perfect
for folks who want to protect
hard-earned retirement savings from
future geopolitical uncertainty when you
look back historically what you see is
that when the bottom falls out of
everything else
Gold tends to safeguard savings Birch
gold group has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews an
A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau contact Birch gold group right
now it's for us a free precious metals
information kit that comprehensive
16-page kit reveals how gold and silver
can protect your savings it can legally
move your IRA or 401k out of stocks and
bonds into a precious metals IRA if
that's something you're interested in to
get that no-cost no-obligation kit go to
birchgold.com slash Bend that's
birchgold.com slash bound the folks I
trust with precious metals investing
birchgold.com slash bone all right so we
are still living in the aftermath of all
the revelations about Paul Manafort
and Michael Kohn we begin today with the
sort of latest updates on the Michael
Cohen situation because Michael Kohn it
turns out is the greater threat to the
President of the United States then is
Paul Manafort to recap Michael Cohen
pled guilty to campaign finance
violations and he suggested that the
President had informed him and told him
to commit these campaign finance
violations he'd instructed him to create
all these shell corporations and avoid
going from normal disclosure routes in
order to pay off to separate women Karen
McDougal and stormy Daniels with whom he
had once had sex just before the
election in order to impact the election
now there are a couple of cases today as
to why this is not actually legal
violation one of those cases being made
by Bradley Smith I discussed this over
the last couple days he's a former
chairman of the Federal Election
Commission he has a piece over at The
Washington Post about this and what he
basically
argues is that it is not a campaign
expenditure when you are paying off a
former lover his rationale is that this
is a personal expenditure you may be
doing it for a variety of reasons maybe
you're doing it because you want to
avoid ticking off your wife that was
John Edwards his case he said that he
silenced real hunter remember the 2008
presidential candidate for the Democrats
he had knocked up a woman who is not his
cancer-ridden wife because John Edwards
is a piece of human trash and then he
had basically had his donors pay the
woman a million dollars to shut up that
ended up coming out he ended up being
prosecuted for it his case was that he
was paying off real hunter because he
didn't want to tick off his wife it had
nothing to do with the election that was
dubious he was tried on it there was a
hung jury and he ended up basically
getting off well that's sort of the case
that Bradley Smith is making he is
saying under the theory that then
candidate Donald Trump's personal
attorney Michael Cohen violated campaign
finance laws by arranging hush money
payments to women accusing Trump of
affairs the answer would seem to be yes
to the question of whether a business
owner running for political office
deciding to pay bonuses to him to his
employees would be a campaign
expenditure he says that that's a
problem that we can't equate everything
with a campaign expenditure everything
you do in your own interest or that
influences a campaign can't be a
campaign expenditure you decide to give
your employees a bonus just before the
election that's not necessarily a
campaign expenditure because maybe you
would have given that bonus to your
employees in the absence of the campaign
anyway Bradley Smith says regardless of
what Cohn agreed to in a plea bargain
hush money payments to mistresses are
not really campaign expenditures it is
true that contribution and expenditure
are defined in the federal election
campaign act as anything for the purpose
of influencing any election and it may
have been intended in hoped that paying
hush money would serve that end the
problem is that almost anything a
candidate does can be interpreted as
intended to influence an election from
buying a good watch to make sure he gets
to places on time to getting a massage
that he feels fit on the campaign trail
to buying a new suits that he looks good
on his abate stage yet having campaign
donors pay for personal luxuries seems
more like bribery than funding campaign
speech so he's making the case that
basically this is not a campaign
expenditure this is a personal
expenditure by the President of the
United States the test under FEC rules
is the so-called irrespective test the
irrespective test says would this
expenditure have been made irrespective
of whether the campaign was happening
and as I've argued I think that there's
a plausible case Trump could say I would
have made this
senator anyway because he has a long
history of pressuring women to stay
silent and paying women off to stay
silent back in 2011 he basically
threatened to sue in Touch magazine for
printing an interview with stormy
Daniels and they backed off and did not
print the interview with stormy Daniels
about her affair with then reality
television producer and star Donald
Trump
so Trump has a case on these grounds
there's a secondary case here and that's
the case being made over at Politico by
a bunch of legal experts they say that
Cohen's admission that he violated
campaign finance law while acting at
Trump's direction is far from rock-solid
proof that the president is also guilty
even if Cohn is being entirely truthful
some lawyers say the fact that Cohen did
something illegal doesn't mean Trump did
anything illegal said gen Barron a
longtime Republican campaign finance
lawyer Cohen said in court on Tuesday
that he acted at Trump's direction and
violated federal election laws by
arranging the payout to stormy Daniels
an adult film actress in the days before
the 2016 election to keep her silent
about what she said was an affair with
Trump a decade earlier Andrew gruel
however University of Iowa law professor
he says under the law it's quite easy
for two people involved in the same act
to have different criminal consequences
that distinction is particularly
critical in campaign finance cases
because the law limits criminal
prosecution for campaign finance
violations two instances where someone
quote knowingly and willfully defied
legal requirements so in other words if
Trump called up Michael Cohen and he
said dude I'd like for you to make this
go away and Michael Cohen says don't
worry I'll take care of it
that is not Trump being complicit in a
campaign finance violation because he
assumes that Cohen knows all the legal
requirements
if however Trump says to Michael Cohen
listen I need you to make this go away
and it doesn't matter if you violate
campaign finance law or I know that we
should shield this from public scrutiny
by using a bunch of shell corporations
and let's say Cohen has him on tape
saying all of that stuff then it looks
more like a campaign create a criminal
campaign finance violation Cohen said
under oath the most damaging information
that the President of the United States
committed a crime and covered it up but
that is not actually indicative that the
president has criminal intent so this
one lawyer Gen Baron says in order to
prove criminal intent you have to point
to evidence that the actors knew or had
reason to know than what they were doing
was illegal Trump can simply claim
ignorance and that may in fact be the
case that he is making right that may be
his strongest case he sort of made that
case a little bit yesterday we'll get to
Trump's response to all of this
so Trump has
of Defense's that are relatively robust
here defense number one I pay off limit
all the time this wasn't a campaign
expenditure defense number two even if
it was a campaign expenditure I didn't
know the rules because I have people
whose job it is to know that stuff and I
didn't order anyone knowingly to violate
campaign finance laws because why the
hell would I do that also a relatively
strong defense so ignorant and
sluttiness are the president's two
defenses and both are quite plausible
because the president gets around and
has for a long time and has paid women
to shut up for apparently a long time
and because the president is not exactly
a legal expert despite his own belief
that he is and president Trump is
actually a terrible legal crying because
he thinks he knows more than his lawyers
which is always the first mark of a bad
legal claim in fact if God could have
come up with a bad legal client in the
laboratory before putting him on earth
he'd look a lot like Donald Trump who
just will not let his lawyers do their
job
I'm Chuck Todd I actually asked lanny
davis trucks out over at MSNBC s lanny
davis was Michael Cohen's lawyer and
this is the great irony of course is
lanny davis was was bill clinton's water
back during the engagement scandal
tonight whipped sides and lanny davis is
now going after the president he is
asked by Chuck Todd if there's any
corroborate of evidence that Michael
Cohen is telling the truth that when
Michael Cohen says that Trump told him
to violate campaign finance law is there
any evidence that corroborates this he
rose Lanny Davis's answer does the SDN y
have physical evidence in their hands
that or is this still on Michael Cohen's
word versus the president's word if I
was trying to give you your answer Chuck
the answer is number one the Trump team
and mr. Giuliani have admitted that the
money was paid number two there is
physical and electronic evidence that
the money was paid to miss Daniels from
the Trump conduit who was mr. Cohen and
it's all documented okay but that
doesn't answer the question okay we know
that the money was passed along the
question is whether Trump had intended
to avoid campaign finance law and that
is not actually documented as what Lanny
Davis seems to be saying so just because
the money passed hands which we all
assume happened and just because Trump
told Cohen to solve the problem which we
all assume happened doesn't mean that
Trump actually had intent to violate
campaign finance line now the great
irony of the situation is that Hillary
Clinton was allowed to get away with
creating a
had server and then destroying
information on the private server
supposedly because she didn't have
intent that's pretty clear she actually
did have intent to destroy information
and violate the law but Trump probably
didn't have intent here and so by the
same standard he should probably not be
criminally liable unless they have
actual evidence that he knew that the
law was being violated and he said I
don't care go ahead and violate the law
anyway it also doesn't help that Michael
Cohen happens to be a particularly
sleazy liar and everybody sort of knows
it whether the newfound respect for
Michael Cohen's honesty is sort of
astonishing from folks on the left you
can see that folks on the left even
really don't believe Michael Khan they
think he's a liar and a screwball Lanny
Davis was on national television
yesterday and on NBC News and he
actually said that they'd open a legal
defense fund for Michael Kony ask people
to contribute and the audience started
laughing at him it's really funny but
could I just take one opportunity to
remind everyone that Michael Cohen has
suffered a tragic and difficult
experience with his family he's without
resources and we've set up a website
called Michael Cohen truths calm that
we're hoping that he will get some help
from the American people so we can
continue to tell the truth the audience
is that I don't know if you're ready to
donate Lanny but I we did check before
we went to air and honest against the
appropriate response by the way his
Legal Defense Fund is raised like
$150,000 it's raised a bunch of money
50,000 of those dollars apparently came
from the CEO of NASCAR first time an odd
reason that nobody can really explain so
all of that is good stuff again the
president has actually three pretty good
defenses Michael Cohen is a liar okay
fair enough Michael Cohen is a liar too
I sleep with every one of them pay them
off also a fairly good defense and
defense number three I don't know what
the hell I'm doing with regard to legal
stuff he's my lawyer it's his job to
know that stuff also a pretty good
defense so all of the talk about Trump
being necessarily legally on the ropes
maybe he is maybe he's not I mean he's
certainly more jeopardy than he was two
days ago but that's not it's not
indicative that this is sort of an
open-and-shut case
Bret Stephens of the New York Times is a
whole thing today about how Trump should
immediately be impeached the evidence
seemed quite there yet of criminal
action we all knew that Trump is is a
man who lacks character in a lot of
particular areas but that's not the same
thing quite as criminal activity I'll
get to the White House's response to all
of this
just a second plus and palm Anna for
updates but first let's talk about the
possibility of a natural disaster or god
forbid some sort of situation that
prevents you from having access to the
grocery store it's important that you
have some sort of emergency food supply
available in your house I mean the
government recommends the ought to have
some emergency food in your house that
you should have you should have water in
your house
and you ought to pay attention to that
because you ought to be prepared you can
trust my Patriot supply for that food
storage so you'll be ready for
earthquakes hurricanes long term power
outages and more Hawaii's about to get
hit by a hurricane apparently and you
know you hope that the folks there are
prepared for it you should be prepared
as well every person in your household
should have a two-week emergency food
supply from my Patriot supply these kids
are only 75 bucks right now
they contain ninety two servings of
breakfasts lunches and dinners take
action call eight eight eight eight oh
three fourteen thirteen or go to my
special website prepare with been calm
the food lasts up to twenty five years
in storage
meals compact and rugged slimline tote
as well only seventy five bucks
rest tonight knowing that you're
prepared order your food kits at eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen or prepare with been calm
that's eight eight eight eight o 31413
or prepare with been calm again eight
eight eight eight o 31413 or prepare
with been calm that ensures that you are
essentially protected against the need
for emergency food because you'll be
prepared prepare with been calm go check
it out right now so with all of this
said the strongest defenses the
president has are I get around I'm dumb
about the law Michael Cohen's a liar
right those are his strongest defenses
his strongest defense is not I am by
nature a truth teller that is not the
president strongest defense because he's
not okay be honest about this the
president is not known for his veracity
on a wide variety of issues he may be at
root a truth teller on some matters
political I think that's true but he
also likes to fib a fair bit and so when
Sarah Sanders got up Sarah Huckabee
Sanders yesterday at the White House
when she got up and she was asked
whether Trump is lying she got very
offended and it didn't play all that
great the American people because so
many people now look back at that
him on Air Force One saying he knew
nothing about these payments when in
fact we now know he knew everything
about this payment so has he lied look
again I think that's an ridiculous
accusation the president in this matter
is done nothing wrong and there are no
charges against him okay so he's done
nothing wrong there no charges against
him no charges against him it's a bad
defense he never lies a bad defense is
offensive to ask whether he lied he
literally was on air fireman what that
reporter says is true he was on Air
Force One he was asked about paying off
stormy Daniels and Karen McDougal and he
said I had no knowledge that any of that
stuff was happening that was not true
okay so that's not his best defense
again I've laid forth three separate
defenses for the president all of which
are fairly robust his best defense is
not I can't be indicted and I never lie
that's not his best defense but Sanders
said repeatedly that Trump can't be
indicted again he can't be that indicted
probably because he's presidents of the
United States but that's not a case that
he's not guilty of a crime there are a
bunch of other cases he's not guilty of
a crime but the statement that he can't
be indicted that's like saying well I
you know I was acquitted on a murder
charge and then it turns out actually
murdered the person I can't be tried
again because of double jeopardy well
that's true that is legally true it also
doesn't mean that you didn't necessarily
murder the person hears like OJ Simpson
clearly murdered Nicole Simpson he was
acquitted and he can't be retried under
double jeopardy if somebody were to ask
him Oh J are you in a sense of killing
your wife and he said can't be tried
again you might assume well maybe he's a
little bit guilty here is Sarah Huckabee
Sanders though saying the president is
innocent because he can't be indicted
which is which is again legally not
tenable as the president said we've
stated many times he did nothing wrong
there are no charges against him as the
president has stated on numerous
occasions he did nothing wrong there are
no charges against him in this the
president in this matter is done nothing
wrong and there are no charges against
him what the president has stated a
number of times he did nothing wrong
there are no charges against him he just
kept saying this over and over right
there's it he did nothing wrong there no
charges against him he did nothing wrong
he's a statement you know the you can
say doesn't something morally wrong but
he did nothing legally wrong would be
the end of the case there are no charges
against him is not part of the case
there are no charges against him because
he's the president of the United States
and you cannot under federal law have a
federal law enforcement agency indict a
sitting president of the United States
okay meanwhile we have up to
on the Paul Manafort case so president
Trump has come out very strongly in
favor of Paul Mann afford he's defended
Paul Manafort we're gonna get two
presidents Trump response to all of this
in just one second because he's been
very prolific on Twitter and then he did
a very long interview this morning on
Fox and Friends as well and he talked to
Ainsley Earhardt yesterday but the
update on Paul Manafort is that a lot of
people on the right have been saying
that poem anna fort was railroaded and
the case that they're making is that
because he was acquitted or because of
the jury hang did he wasn't acquitted he
was the jury the jury hung on ten
separate charges that this means that he
was innocent of those charges and the
whole thing is some sort of witch-hunt
he was convicted on a charges one of the
jurors was on Fox News last night with
shannon bream
she's a trump supporter she explained
that basically there was one person in
the room who made it a hung jury as
opposed to everybody so basically if it
not been from one juror he would been
convicted on all accounts here's the
juror explaining okay how close I want
to know did this jury come to convicting
Paul Manafort on all 18 counts by one
that was one holdout the person a female
juror was we all tried to convince her
to look at the paper trail we laid it
out in front of her again and again and
she still said that she had a reasonable
doubt and that's the way the jury work
okay so the idea that this was just all
the witch hunts again they're a bunch of
Trump supporters on that jury and
manifold was convicted on eight counts
anyway so it's not the witch hunt if
there is a witch hunt the witch hunt
would have to do a lot more with the
Muller investigation looking a Russian
collusion but it would have nothing to
do with Paul Manafort being guilty of
stuff Paul manna for it was guilty of
stuff end of story and when people say
you know if the Special Counsel dug into
you you would find something my answer
would be well depends on what he finds
if he finds that I was actively taking
money from a foreign government in order
to manipulate the American political
process which is sort of what manna fort
was doing prior to the election had
nothing to do with Trump then that's a
crime you know there's not say that the
government should be able to go through
everybody's books at will but he was
convicted of eight federal felonies and
would have been convicted of another ten
if there hadn't been one holdout on the
jury so let's reserve the witch hunt
language for actual witch hunts let's
not reserved the witch hunt
which for when there's actually a lady
running around in an actual witch's hat
riding a broom and casting curses by
killing cats well how about that
how about we saved the witch hunt
language for you no actual witch hunts
Ainsley Earhardt k-much said the Trump
is actually considering pardoning mana
for Trump has been very warm toward mana
Ford he says that mana fort is great guy
because he didn't squeal which again
doesn't make the president sound
particularly innocent the president is
his own worst advocate when it comes to
matters legal here Ainsley Ainsley
Earhardt came out and she said the Trump
is considering pardoning Paul mana
fortune then walked that back a little
bit ari fleischer tweeted out he said if
Trump pardons mana for then it might be
worth considering impeachment he says I
don't care for Trump's style he can be
too offensive and divisive fleischer of
course was press secretary under george
w bush I like many of his policies if he
fires mullah or pardons mana for I
consider impeachment but nothing so far
merits impeachment the remedy for those
who can't stand him is political beat
him in 2020 if you can I think so far
ari fleischer is basically correct so
all of the talk about palm anna fort it
amounts to nothing I'm just puzzled as
to why the president continues to defend
him meanwhile the state of New York is
looking at going after president Trump
as well this poses a significant serious
difficulty for the president because the
president can be indicted on state
charges so if you commit a murder as
president of the United States there is
nothing in the Constitution that forbids
a state prosecutor from bringing you up
on violation of state law the reason the
president can be indicted under federal
law is because the president controls
the federal executive branch but the
President does not control state law
which is why the president can't for
example pardon state crimes right he
can't pardon a state murderer for
example well New York State
investigators have now subpoenaed
Michael Cohen the president's former
personal lawyer according to state
officials as part of a probe into the
Donald J Trump foundation they have a
lot of evidence that the Donald J Trump
foundation was basically being used as a
pass-through for Trump to pay personal
expenses it's not a criminal matter yet
right the tax department in New York
doesn't have the jurisdiction to pursue
criminal charges but it's discovered
information valuable to the
investigation of the Trump foundation it
would then be referred to the New York
State Attorney General I have very
little doubt that the New York Attorney
General would have very little trouble
trying to pursue a criminal
investigation into president Trump
Barbara Underwood hates President Trump
with a passion of a thousand burning
sons so you could see is a state
prosecution against the president and he
is not in fact immune to state
prosecution under
federal law so this is a continuing
serious problem for the president it's
you know it would be great if we'd have
to deal with any of this stuff we'll
have to deal with the charges they come
and evaluate them as they come now in a
second we're going to get to the
president's response to all of this some
of which is good some of which is bad
most of which is kind of bad but we'll
get to that in just second first let's
talk about your suit so look dudes you
want to look like James Bond okay you
want to be wearing a tailored suit you
want to look like you are dressed to the
nines every time you put on a suit and
you go to a meeting but you're buying an
off-the-rack suit to cost you like two
hundred bucks and it hangs on you like
drapes this is why you need instead to
go over to Indo Chino calm Indo chinos
the world's largest made-to-measure
menswear company they've been featured
in major publications including GQ
Forbes and Fast Company they make suits
and shirts made your exact measurements
for a great fit dudes love the wide
selection of high quality fabrics the
option to personalize all the details
including lapel lining and monogram
here's how it works you go to their
showroom they have it in a bunch of
major cities or you go to Enzo Chino
calm you can pick your fabric choose
your customization submit your
measurements it's actually a lot of fun
and again it feels like you're going
into like Q's laboratory in James Bond
except this time you're getting a
tailored suit you go in there and they
ask you how exactly you want the suit to
look how you want it to fit what you
what you want the personalizations to be
and then they said it's you and it's
made to order my listeners can get any
premium Enzo Chino suit this week for
just 379 bucks at Indo Chino comm when
entering Schapiro at checkout it's 50%
off the regular price for a made to
measure premium suit shipping is free
Indo Chino kaam promo code Shapiro's for
any premium suit for just 379 bucks
again free shipping that's Indo Chino
kaam promo code Shapiro you get an
awesome looking suit for the price of an
off-the-rack suit and it's tailored to
you endo Chino comm promo code Shapiro
for that special discount go check it
out right now
ok so president Trump has responded to
all this in a variety of ways so
yesterday he was on with Ainsley
Earhardt over at Fox News and he said I
paid for stormy Daniels so remember this
is a guy who said that he didn't even
know about the stormy Daniels pay off
now he is saying that he paid for stormy
Daniels the case in favor of him saying
this is that he doesn't think he
violated federal finance law he didn't
know his violation of federal finance
law he still goes who knows a violation
of federal finance laws how can you say
he had intent to violate federal finance
law that's the charitable reading the
unshared
is that he just admitted to a federal
crime because if he personally paid for
a campaign expenditure and admitted to
it then he just admitted to a federal
crime on national television this is why
you should let your lawyers do the
talking mr. president here is the
President of the United States talking
to Ainsley Earhardt did you know about
the payments later on I knew later on
but you have to understand anything what
he did and they weren't taken out of
campaign finance that's a big thing
that's a much bigger thing did they come
out of the campaign they didn't come out
of the campaign they came from me and I
tweeted about it you know I put I don't
know if you know but I tweeted about the
payments but they didn't come out of
campaign in fact my first question when
I heard about it was did they come out
of the campaign okay so it's a this is
not a smart line of attack because if in
fact he knew that the money was going to
be used to pay off stormy Daniels and
Karen McDougal in violation of federal
campaign finance law then him saying I
signed it personally is in fact the
crime if it's a campaign expenditure
it's supposed to come from campaign
funding and if he wants to spend on his
own behalf he's supposed to report it so
that's not particularly great and the
president also decided that it would be
worthwhile to tweet out about Michael
Cohen again today so he tweeted out the
only thing I have done wrong is to win
an election that was expected to be won
by a crooked Hillary Clinton and the
Democrats the problem is they forgot to
campaign in numerous states so fact
check 3/4 true half true so it is true
that if he had not won none of this
would be an issue it is also true that
the media are very pissed and that he
won it is not really super true that the
only thing he did wrong was to win the
election it turns out that shipping
women not your wife and then paying them
hundreds of thousands of dollars to shut
up in advance of an election it doesn't
go in like the book of virtues it's
probably not like the best thing to do
but when it but you know the he's right
that the media are treating this in a
way differently than they would treat a
Democrat certainly that wasn't the end
of it though
the president also did an interview this
morning on on Fox News it was a fairly
lengthy interview and he talked about a
wide variety of topics one of the things
that he talked about is Michael Cohen
flipping on him and he makes a comment
that again this is why you let your
lawyers do the talking mr. president let
your lawyers are the talking mr.
president my good
he comes out and he says that when
people flip flipping ought to be illegal
right so getting somebody to testify in
exchange for reduced sentence that
should be illegal well for a
law-and-order guy that's a real weird
statement because every drug ring that
has ever been ruled up has been rolled
up on the basis of people pleading to
lesser crimes in order for them to get
some sort of advantage and then testify
against their buddies right every single
every single RICO case every single drug
case half of criminal cases are based on
flipping people so you can move up the
chain right flipping people is a is a
long honored tradition and the reason
for that is because if you couldn't flip
people if you couldn't offer them a
reduced sentence or protection or some
sort of concession why wouldn't they
just go by omerta why wouldn't they just
keep silent in order to maintain loyalty
with the folks who they are afraid will
kill them in prison or in order to
maintain loyalty with the folks are
gonna pay their family while they stay
in jail for a longer period of time
here's President Trump though saying
that flipping people ought to be illegal
this is just not smart it makes him look
guilty even if he's not it's just okay
here is make up stories this whole thing
about flipping they call it I know all
about flipping for 30 40 years I've been
watching flippers everything's wonderful
and then they get 10 years in jail and
they they flip on whoever the next
highest one is or as high as you can go
it almost sort of be outlawed it's not
fair what in the living hell I mean he
sounds like John Gotti here yeah he
should not be doing this right the fact
is when the president says I'm watching
us for 30 years okay so you can actually
search his tweet history he is not once
tweeted about flipping not once until
now has he discuss flipping publicly not
once as he said you know what this
Criminal Procedure is really bad only
when someone flips on him then all of a
sudden flipping is really really really
bad and presumably when it comes to
cracking down on drug crimes or illegal
immigration he's a very tough law and
order president he doesn't care about
flipping it's only flipping applies when
it comes to him so I guess that the the
we can all expect Republican support for
the don't rat on people act of 2018 it's
just not not good stuff then the
president makes a separate case he says
I shouldn't be impeached not because I'm
innocent I shouldn't be impeached
because if I did then the market would
crash again oh yeah yeah yeah I'll tell
you what if I ever got a piece I think
the market would crash I think everybody
would be very poor because without this
thinking you would see you would see
numbers that you wouldn't believe in
reverse ok so yeah maybe that's true
maybe that's not the fact is that after
the impeachment Clinton the market
continued to go up I think that the
market really does not like uncertainty
the market is so it's probably true that
the market would take a hit the market
took a hit a couple of days ago when all
these revelations from Michael Cohen
broke so yes the market doesn't like
uncertainty would it adjust with
President Mike Pence you know yeah sure
I mean the answer is probably yes
although a Trump impeachment would
probably ding the market I don't think
so Thalia wrong here I think the reason
that it would zing the market is because
the markets fear Democratic takeover of
the House Senate and presidency and a
massive upswing and regulation that
would dampen the ability to invest right
if they've people were afraid that
Elizabeth Warren was gonna be the next
president with a Democratic Congress
then that might ding the market so Trump
isn't entirely wrong here but again his
strongest case here is I didn't do
anything wrong he should just come out
and say I don't know the law I didn't
know the law to pretend I'm some sort of
campaign finance expert is silly
there's there's such ample defenses
available to him but this is where the
president's ego gets in the way of his
own success now the president loves him
some president I mean Donald Trump is a
big fan of Donald Trump and because he's
a big fan of Donald Trump he's never
able to admit to things that we all know
are true like the fact that he goes
around sleeping with porn stars and
paying them off like we all know that's
true I'm not gonna pretend that he's a
King David character when it comes to
his character he's not and we all know
that that was baked into the cake if he
would just say that I think everybody
would be like okay fine that's a
plausible case that's what Bill Clinton
basically did Bill Clinton basically
says yeah that's what I do I'll go
around sticking cigars and women that's
what I'll do and everybody was like okay
guess so yep that's that's accurate if
the president just said that stuff he
said listen I'm ignorant about the law
and I pay off ladies everybody be like
yeah kind of knew that already kinda
knew that already that was already known
but instead the president keeps saying
that he's a legal expert on things that
he's been talking about flipping for 30
years he has never once talked about
flipping the weekend fine and how do you
know that the president is
a little bit egotistic because here's
what he was asked to grade his
presidency so far I will give you three
guesses how he graded his presidency so
far three guesses I don't think it's
going to take three guesses for you so I
give myself an A+ I don't think any
president has ever done what I've done
in this short we haven't even been two
years biggest tax cuts in history I
would say I would honestly give myself
an A+ and so would many other people yes
many other people who worked for you and
or in Congress and want to get things
done with you listen I've been very
positive about the president's policy
I've given him an a-minus when it comes
to his executive policy I have given him
like a C+ when it comes to legislative
policy maybe a b-minus and when it comes
to rhetoric keys a dear enough I mean
that's just the way that it is and
people may disagree with that although I
can assure you there are a lot of folks
in the administration who basically
agree with that assessment but the fact
that the president gives himself an A+
ego is a killer okay it's true for you
it's true for me anybody who gets too
over their skis on ego who never
reflects for a second and thinks maybe
there's something I'm bad at one of the
worst things you can do in life is
overestimate your own skillset or
suggest that you have a skill set where
you have none there's certain things I'm
just bad at okay I'm not the world's
most athletic human right there I'm not
I'm good at math but I'm not great at
math right there are certain things I
just don't know a lot about if I don't
admit that stuff you get yourself in
real trouble and that's particularly
true when you are talking about matters
legal yeah there are lawyers for a
reason who go to law school and spend
years practicing it is not a coincidence
that President Trump has fired basically
everywhere he's ever worked with at a
certain point when you look at a client
and every one of their lawyers has
failed you have to think maybe it's not
the lawyers maybe it's the client so the
President of the United States may
having making real trouble for himself
he didn't stop there we get to some more
of his comments in just a second first
let's talk about bravo company
manufacturing when the founders crafted
the constitution the first thing they
did was to make sacred the rights of the
individual to share their ideas without
limitation by the government and to
protect that they created the second
amendment the second enumerated right
the right of the population to protect
that speech and their rights with force
and that is why I am a big Second
Amendment supporter the same thing holds
true for the folks at Bravo company
manufacturing Bravo Company
manufacturing was started in a garage by
a marine vet more than two decades ago
to build profession
great product that meets combat
standards BCM believes the same level of
protection should be provided to every
American as long as you're a law-abiding
citizen who wants to protect your rights
BCM is not a supporting arms company
they design engineer and manufacture
life-saving equipment this isn't about
hunting it's not about going to the
range it's about will this thing
function if god forbid there's somebody
in your house trying to hurt you or if
you are in in the midst of a tyrannical
government rise which I know I know
folks on the Left likes you discount
this until Donald Trump is president but
one of the reasons we don't have a
tyrannical government is particularly
the threat of a population that is armed
BCM wants to make weapons that assume
each rifle leaving their shop will be
used in a life-or-death situation by a
responsible citizen law enforcement
officer or a soldier overseas each
component of a BCM rifle is hand
assembled and tested by Americans to a
life-saving standard they want to
provide tools it will not fail the user
when it's not just a paper target but
it's somebody coming to do them harm to
learn more about bravo company
manufacturing head on over to bravo
company MFG comm you can discover more
about their product special officer
offers and upcoming news that's Bravo
Company MFG calm and if you want to
check them out you want to take a look
at what they do go to youtube.com slash
Bravo Company USA that's youtube.com
slash Bravo Company USA Bravo Company
MFG comm go check it out right now okay
so in just a second we will get to the
the media's response to everything Trump
related plus the president sounds off on
South Africa I have some thoughts but
first we're gonna have to go over to
daily wire comm so for $9.99 a month you
can get a subscription to daily wire.com
rest of this show live rustic Levens
show live restore Knowles our show live
be part of the mailbag which we are
doing tomorrow I can't believe it is
only Thursday but yes tomorrow is Friday
and that means that you want to get your
mailbag questions and now so subscribe
today 99 bucks a year it gets you this
the very greatest in all beverage
vessels gaze upon it gaze upon the
Wonder you can see the strength seeping
into my body just from holding the
leftist here's hot or called tumblr it
is a magnificent magnificent piece of
vessel ring so go check that out for 99
bucks a year it's cheaper than the
monthly
also check us out at YouTube and and
subscribe there check us out at iTunes
SoundCloud anyplace you listen to
podcasts or watch subscribe so you get
our Sunday special have clay Travis on
this Sunday we have a bunch of great
guests coming up like really we're back
loading great guests now so go check it
out over there we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so the president continues to defend
Paul Manafort again not he I don't see
why Paul Manafort was convicted of a
bunch of stuff that had nothing to do
with Trump now the cynical reason he'd
protect Paul Manafort is because he's
afraid that if he doesn't talk about pub
pub Paul Manafort is great Paul Manafort
flips to but the non cynical reason is
that he just thinks anybody in his orbit
who's targeted as targeted unfairly in
any case the president is not his own
best advocate here I know that a lot of
his fans think that he's always his own
best advocate but that is just not true
and it's not true on matters with regard
to with regard to law so you know I
would hope that the president would
would kind of leave off here and let his
lawyers do the rest meanwhile the media
are just champing at the bit over this
Chuck Todd over at NBC you know in doing
some real journalism in being very
objective here he says that Paul Ryan
should drop impeachment papers because I
remember when all of the members of the
media were calling on Democrats to go
along with impeachment of President
Clinton for committing actual perjury
while he was presidents of the United
States oh no wait that didn't happen at
all
I also don't remember calls for
impeachment of President Obama over the
IRS scandal or Benghazi or the Fast &
Furious scandal or any of the other
scandals that occurred during the during
the Obama administration you wanna read
about all those scandals I wrote an
entire book on them it's called the the
People vs Barack Obama so go check that
out but Chuck Todd says Paul Ryan should
start drawing up impeachment papers now
Ryan's retiring I think he actually
could do the party a favor and if you
just start the procedure in the House
Judiciary Committee you give some home
you give some place for Republicans
getting nervous to say hey you know what
let's start an investigation and we'll
go from there okay how about everybody
just saying we won't obstruct the
investigation and there's already
investigation going on the mother
investigation continues and Republicans
have already said that if it's not
obstruct if it's obstructed it's gonna
be a problem okay the same thing holds
true
with regard to the SD NY investigation I
assume but the idea that Republicans are
gonna start impeachment proceedings
based on the information that we have
now it's a little early Chuck Todd also
let's be real about what impeachment is
hey impeachment is a political remedy
impeachment is not a legal remedy that's
not how it was originally conceived the
founders thought that impeachment was
going to be a legal remedy that Congress
would use impeachment in order to check
the executive branch in reality
impeachment has been used
extraordinarily
like people in politics tend to want
elections to provide the referendum on
the sitting president of the United
States they don't tend to want to oust
people even for legal violations because
they'd rather have the people taken on
their own backs to get rid of a
particular president there have only
been three impeachment proceedings in
America's history with regard to
presidents one was Andrew Johnson
impeached in the house not convicted in
the Senate
Bill Clinton impeached in the house not
convicted in the Senate and Richard
Nixon impeachment proceedings never
really got started because Nixon knew he
would be impeached and he resigned so
the sudden the sudden shift toward we
have to have a bipartisan view of
impeachment is kind of ridiculous coming
from the same media that thought it was
absolutely absurd for Republicans to try
to impeach President Clinton back in
1998 Elizabeth Warren though understands
this is where the heart of the base is
she is probably one of the frontrunners
for the 2020 nomination among Democrats
and she said on CNN that she is not
nervous to bring up the topic of
impeachment of course why would she be
she's from Massachusetts the chances
that she meets any sort of resistance
here aren't slim and none I'm not
nervous I just want to be effective and
the way that any of us are effective is
to say let's get all of the evidence
let's get all of the pieces out there
protect Robert Muller let him finish his
investigation let him make a full and
fair report to all of the American
people okay so what exactly are
Democrats looking for in this whole
proceeding what they're really looking
for is an excuse to obstruct Trump's
agenda we all know this Kamala Harris
who's our execrable senator I've been
using that word a lot because a lot of
execrable people lately but Kamala
Harris is our execrable senator here in
the state of California she came out and
she says you know because Trump is now
basically an unindicted co-conspirator
which he is not I mean that's an actual
legal term that is not used in the
indictment of Michael Cohen because he's
an indicted unindicted co-conspirator
says Kamala Harris
we should not move forward on the
nomination of Brett Kavanaugh for the
Supreme Court this does not follow let's
say John Donald Trump or remove tomorrow
let's say Donald Trump resigned tomorrow
who would become president it wouldn't
be Kamala Harris when me Hillary Clinton
it would be Mike Pence would then move
full full scale forward on the
nomination of Brett Kavanaugh so this is
just stupidity but it demonstrates that
the real the real force behind
impeachment has much more to do with
obstructing the President's agenda than
with legal ire at the president's miss
action here even before this happened
there was no
that the process was horribly flawed a
court of the United States of America
has accepted a guilty plea from someone
who was the lawyer for the President of
the United States and that person in
pleading guilty basically made very
clear that it was the then candidate and
now the president of the United States
who directed him to commit a crime this
is a serious matter yeah this is I love
I love the faux seriousness from Kamala
Harris who was one of the worst attorney
generals in the history of the state of
California refusing to enforce the law
enforcing what wasn't appropriate and
now she's of course the senator who's
going to use this this sort of supposed
legal ire to go after president Trump
there there's a fair bit of hypocrisy on
this yeah they're gonna hold up Brett
Kavanaugh over Trump come on come on we
all know what this is really about we
are all very well aware of what this is
all really about okay meanwhile the
president is getting himself in I think
hot water from the left but I don't
think appropriately because yesterday he
tweeted out that he wanted to look into
the situation in South Africa regarding
land seizures so for folks who have not
been following the situation in South
Africa because we don't tend to follow
foreign policy that much in the United
States what's been happening is that the
South African government which is
dominated by the left has decided that
they want to seize the land of white
farmers in recompense for apartheid
apartheid ended in 1994 I believe under
the the Nelson Mandela it was it started
to collapse already in the late 80s and
then it was formally ended in in 94 by
Mandela in any case the I don't want to
get the the history of that wrong so I'm
actually going to look that up right now
so in an in any case the South African
government decides yeah I mean that's
that's right in April 27 1994 is when it
was formally ended in any case the
President of the United States is
commenting on the fact that the South
African government now wants to seize
land that is owned by white folks in
South Africa and redistributed this is
bad policy for South Africa it's
particularly bad policy because it is
undermining the rule of law and the real
problems in South Africa have very
little to do with white land ownership
and they have a lot more to do with the
fact that rule of law has collapsed in
South Africa the crime rates are
extraordinarily high they've an
unemployment
twenty-eight percent they've
significantly high inflation they have
water crisis that's been ongoing for
years at this point is a distraction
from the government of South Africa to
the people of South Africa on a racial
basis and it is true that apartheid was
evil and it has carried over into into
land ownership today but the idea that
you can just seize property from white
landowners and not undermine the rule of
law which undermines foreign investment
and the capacity to trust in your
ability to own private property in South
Africa is of course very silly so Trump
tweeted out I've as Secretary of State
Pompeyo to closely study the South
Africa land and farm teachers and
expropriations and the large scale
killing of farmers South African
government is now seizing land from
white farmers Tucker Carlson Fox News so
he was watching Fox News last night and
he decided this was gonna drive policy
he's not wrong about the land
expropriate expropriations the left
which is going nuts over this suggesting
that this is racial it's racially
motivated the United States if it were
the reverse if you were black landowners
who are having their land seized by
white people
the president would certainly have a
right to intervene and the same is true
here and there's already been talk about
the United States government getting
active on the international stage over
all of this the Cato Institute has
issued a statement regarding the dire
consequences awaiting South Africa
should due process fail land
expropriation without compensation
what's happening there as the government
is not even saying that they're going to
pay people for their land they're
basically just grabbing land without
even recompense which is which is a
crazy crazy policy here is is some audio
of the the leader of South Africa the
the prime minister of South Africa his
his name is Rama foes up talking about
this land expropriation on Tuesday South
Africans through their publicly elected
representatives in Parliament voted
overwhelmingly in support of the motion
to accelerate equitable land
redistribution through expropriation of
land without compensation okay that's a
crazy policy there's a Cyril Ramaphosa
the reason he's doing this is because
he's being outflanked by radicals the
ruling African National Congress amended
but supported the motion to actually
expropriate land without any sort of
compensation he's being outflanked
by the radical left economic freedom
fighters these are folks who wear red
berets like that illegitimate communists
whose leader Julius Malema told the
country's parliament we must ensure that
we restore the dignity of our people
without compensating the criminals who
stole our land so they're not going to
pay people now you may think that the
people who own the land committed a
crime you'd actually have to look at
which people owning the land committed
the crimes maybe that's true maybe
that's not but to remove land from
people without actually paying them on
the governmental level especially when
it wouldn't cost all that much money to
pay them off and make them leave to do
that undermines rule of law in South
Africa and the president isn't wrong to
point that out now there's been a lot of
focus on so-called farmers in South
Africa a lot of these farms aren't owned
by white folks and the murder rate on
these farms is is high but the murder
rate across South Africa is particularly
high the statistics are very much in
doubt as to whether there is a higher
rate of targeted killing of whites in
South Africa than blacks in South Africa
the most violent areas of South Africa
include mass killing of or massive
killing anyway now black folks crime
rates are very high over there but to
suggest the president has no place in
saying anything about this and that he's
only doing this because he's a racist as
so many on the Left are saying that is
uh that that's that's pretty silly
that's that's I think an overstatement
by the media which we are getting used
to in large scale okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like my sister
actually recommended this show to me
it's on Netflix it's called I am a
killer and to look inside death row it's
a documentary series so they profile a
bunch of murder cases and they talk to
folks who are on death row it's it's
kind of fascinating because it is fairly
objective it tries to take all sides of
a particular issue it will talk to the
victims of the killing it will talk to
the killer
they'll talk to the family of the killer
and the law enforcement officers and
prosecutors it's as good a piece of
journalism on this stuff as I've seen
him only a couple of episodes in but so
far I'm a fan the shows I'm a killer and
here's a little bit of the trailer I was
convicted for capital murder I was
convicted of capital murder
and I was sentenced to death I did
something so heinous I just fired a shot
I strike them with the axe started
stabbing
let me tie you up I'm gonna kill you oh
I mean it it's it's definitely well done
it's not it's not the fastest moving
thing but it's definitely a well done
seriously you should go check that out
it's well worth saying other things that
I like so the President of the United
States has been making an issue out of
the Mali Tibbets case the Mali Tibbets
case twenty-year-old Iowan girl who was
abducted and murdered by an illegal
immigrant and president Trump issued
comments yesterday a lot of folks were
saying that President Trump was doing
this to distract from all the Coens
stuff the reality is that Trump would
have done this in any case for I mean he
did this during the campaign repeatedly
with Kate Steinle
over in San Francisco so this is this is
nothing new here's President Trump
commenting on it it's one of the reasons
why President Trump continues to retain
popularity is because the contrast
between Trump and the left on issues
like this is pretty astonishing Mali
Tibbets an incredible young woman is now
permanently separated from her family a
person came in from Mexico illegally and
killed her
we need the wall we need our immigration
laws changed the Democrats will never
give them and the wall is being built
we've started it but we also need the
funding for this year's building of the
wall so to the family of Mali Tibbets
all I can say is God bless you this is
why if President Ron would just leave to
his lawyers the rest of the stuff and he
campaigned on this stuff you'd actually
be doing much better in the polls and I
think that yeah he'd be doing well
especially when you contrast this with
the with the sort of idiocy of a lot of
folks on the Left Symone Sanders he's a
commentator over at CNN here's what she
had to tweet a tamale Tibbets matter she
tweeted Mali Tibbets was murdered
because she told the man to leave her
alone while she was jogging her murderer
happens to be undocumented
this isn't about border security this is
about toxic masculinity Mali Tibbets
lost her life because a man couldn't
take her saying no full stop well I
think it's fair to say that when a man
kills a woman that does counts as toxic
masculinity I think it probably counts
as just toxic evil in any case and it
turns out the vast majority of murders
in the United States are committed by
men so I don't think that's totally
wrong but to say that it has nothing to
do with undo
being undocumented is silly he shouldn't
be in the country the question is how
you stop that if Simone Sanders has a
good answer as to how to stop toxic
masculinity like men from killing women
in general that is better than don't let
evil men into the country illegally I'd
like to hear it but this is sort of the
problem with a lot of folks on the Left
they will say things like we have a
problem the problem is toxic masculinity
and it's out there in the air somewhere
I'm not gonna actually provide a
solution to that the solution is sort of
you know like to regen dur our children
the solution is to pretend that
masculinity is inherently bad right and
then those of us say well you know the
other thing we could do is just not let
this piece of crap in the country shake
no we got to talk about toxic
masculinity
you wonder why folks are resounding to
President Trump even still that is the
reason what I mean while some things
that I hate speaking of the attempt to
undermine basic truths there's this
video that has now been I've now been
made aware of it's it's a video that is
promoted at of all places the Huffington
Post because this is the repository for
all stupidity in the United States it's
a video of a trans man which is to say a
woman who believes that she is a man her
name is Cass bliss and she detailed that
Huffington Post what it's like to get
your period when you're not a woman
which as a man I would say is pretty
weird because you need a uterus which
makes you a woman bliss is a non-binary
trans educator and she first went viral
with her bleeding well trans campaign in
2017 to prove the biologically
impossible claim that men have periods
to she recently created a music video
discussing the struggles of having your
period while not identifying his woman
in a quest for menstrual equity so here
is here's the song cut by a woman who
believes she is a man who says that men
have periods and yes it's weird and yes
if this is your solution to toxic
masculinity I'm not going to take you
seriously
[Music]
though I'm not a woman she is building
right outside Jarno Trulli let me bleed
let me play let me read let me play so
I'm not a big with our gendered wombs of
wisdom let us plead itself first of all
not a huge Beatles fan in general but if
you're going to destroy the Beatles this
way I feel bad for the Beatles now and
and this person is saying that we can't
have we can't have tampons anymore
because tampons are gendered when you go
to the when you go to the store they're
all they're like pink and stuff instead
what they should be as they should be
like a manly blue like manly blue
tampons very important and and we should
have tampons in the men's bathroom also
which would be weird since men don't
have uterus but the conflation of sex
with gender is is one of the most
ridiculous aspects of the sort of trans
rights agenda this bizarre notion that
sex and gender are different but then we
will conflate them again so sex is your
biology you are biologically male but
your gender is the ORA gendered female
but then when it comes to going to the
bathroom we are going to treat your
gender as your sex you are a biological
female even though you're a biological
male none of this makes any sense
you wonder why folks are confused and
find this just a there's an article
yesterday was really amazing there's an
article about Blaire white who's a trans
woman meaning a man who believes that he
is a woman or who feels like a woman on
the inside or whatever and Blaire is a
nice person I've been on Blairs show on
YouTube we just discussed exactly this
issue and the yahoo news article about
Blaire white described our conversation
and said that I was anti the trans
community I don't even know what that
means
if by anti the trans community you mean
I am NOT going to suggest that you are a
member of the of the sex to which you
claim membership then okay if you mean
that I don't want you to have all the
rights of a normal human being in the
United States then of course that's not
true of course I think that trans people
should be able to do anything that non
trans people should be able to do in the
United States but no one in the united
states gets to redefine objective
biological terms and then expect me to
go along with the x that's not a thing
that is going to happen but I guess it
again just this idea that you are anti a
person because you're anti a perspective
is a conflation that is intellectually
dishonest
okay other things that I hate - Jimmy
Kimmel has now made clear for the one
hundred and seventy fifth time that he
doesn't want to appeal to Trump fans he
says I don't think that world exists
anymore
he says that he is not gonna bother with
with trying to appease all of these
folks he says I don't think you can look
at things in that way he says that the
world doesn't exist anymore where he can
appeal to of a wide variety of people
he was interview by The Daily Beast the
daily be said in terms of the effect of
politics on your own ratings I know you
said if people who disagreed with you
don't want to watch you don't
particularly care has that ever been an
issue at ABC he said I said he and he
replied maybe I shouldn't have said I
don't care I don't care enough to change
what I'm doing it's probably a more
explicit explanation
I'm sure ABC would love it if my show up
heeled to everyone but I don't think
that world exists anymore and I'm not
comfortable in it I don't really see any
but any other path I also think one of
the biggest mistakes you can make as a
performer is trying to guess what your
audience wants I think you need to do
what you think is right and hope that
works out well I agree with that I also
think that what the audience expects
from a comedian is to be funny and not
to be a crusader for their politics that
is not the same thing as if you just
want to be a political person who
happens to be funny there is a
difference there is a difference I think
the media are gonna continue to fragment
so long as people don't understand which
Lane they are in are you a comedian or
are you're a political guru pick one
pick one you can be a political guru
who's funny that's fine there are plenty
of those but if you're going to be a
comedian theoretically you should be
making comedy about everybody which is
not what folks like Jimmy Kimmel are
doing
it's alienating a lot of the audience
and it's causing that audience to react
politically to cultural flashpoints like
Kimmel already we will be back here
tomorrow with all the latest updates and
the mailbag i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire Ford publishing
production copyright Ford publishing